can you hazard a guess why Europe is
clamping down on speech critical of
Islam when Islam is causing lots of
problems with rape gangs terrorism and
generally being a menace why well I
suppose the first let's say if I was
going to oppose that statement I would
say well perhaps it's a propagandistic
what would you call it conspiracy to
blame what's happening in Europe on
Islamic immigrants I guess part of the
problem is is that at least as far as I
can tell the news has become
sufficiently unreliable because it's so
polarized that we can't really tell
what's going on I mean I think the
reason that Europe is clamping down on
speech critical of Islam is partly the
same reason that the entire Western
world is clamping down on speech that's
critical of anything that is associated
with group identity which is pretty much
any set of ideas that unites people and
it's it's a consequence of the
collective decision that we've made that
egalitarianism and conflict avoidance
constitute the two highest virtues and
they Trump everything else including
free speech now why that's happened this
very very difficult thing to say I mean
I suspect to some degree that it's a
consequence of women becoming involved
in the political system which is
something that we've never experienced
before and women are more agreeable by
nature than men and agreeable people are
are compassionate towards those they see
as suffering and that seems to include
any minority especially when you combine
that with the kind of neo Marxist
doctrine that claims that anyone who has
that is swiped it and I think in the
Islamic situation you get it real
conflict there because it's obviously
the case that many Islamic practices are
not commensurate with postmodern
neo-marxist feminism let's say but they
seem to get a free pass and I guess
that's because the idea that all
cultures are equal Trump's the
requirement for human rights for women
and and maybe the other thing that's
even dark there is that there's a fair
bit of revolutionary fervor in the more
radical end of the left political
spectrum and that radical further is
devoted towards tearing down the
patriarchy and of course that's
basically Western civilization and so if
because Islam isn't part of Western
civilization then it can be seen as an
ally in that in that attempt that's what
it looks like to me I also think you
know that ignorance and and all of that
contribute it isn't obvious that people
who are afraid of such things as
Islamophobia really understand anything
about Islam I wouldn't say I understand
anything about Islam even though I've
read if they're a bit about it it's very
difficult to put yourself inside a
different belief system I'm somewhat
apprehensive about Islam because it
looks to me like it's a totalizing
system as well as a religion and it's a
totalizing system because everything has
to come under its purview including law
and and everything that goes along with
that there's no separation between
church and state and so I don't see how
that's commensurate with the Western
mode of existence and I don't think
people want to have
conversation because they want to say
well no everyone diverse as they are and
important as that diversity is
apparently such that everyone has to be
represented equally the diversity isn't
really of anything about anything
fundamental and we can all get along
without a problem and I'm afraid that
that's extraordinarily naive and then I
suppose there's also an element of
something like Western guilt
I guess perhaps for what has been
described as our imperialist past the
there's been a very long term assault on
on the what would you call moral on the
morality of the West
we're often viewed as the rapers and
pillagers of the world and that sort of
goes along with the environmentalist
ethos and so I think we do have a fair
bit of guilt about that whether it's
warranted or not I mean history is a
bloody nightmare and it doesn't matter
where you look and I would say at least
the West has brought advantages along
with its disadvantages and I think that
our attitude towards individuality is
fundamentally correct and absolutely
vital and I would also say that the only
countries in the world that are
essentially worth living in in any real
sense are the ones that are predicated
on the judeo-christian tradition
and manifested in Western the Western
law D of laws so but there's still
plenty of guilt and there's plenty of
people who well who are what
contemptuous of being as we discussed in
the last question and also angry with
the political system because they're
powerless or maybe they've been hurt by
male authority figures that happens very
frequently and so they have absolutely
no trust in higher in hierarchical
structures and there you might add to
that to certain amount of laziness
because the thing about hierarchical
structures is that they impose values on
people and then in order to progress in
that value structure you have to
discipline yourself and work hard and
many of the radical leftists happen to
be very low in conscientiousness and so
they don't believe in hard work and they
don't believe that people get to where
they're going by hard work and then well
one other thing there's a group of
people I think who are basically
personality disordered and those are the
ones that have never had a positive
relationship with anything that was
masculine so whenever they see anything
masculine that has motive power and that
would include authority and confidence
not just power they assume that that's
tyrannical and it's part of the
postmodern assumption that all power
higher all hierarchies are hierarchies
of power when the truth of the matter is
is that hierarchies in the West are
usually hierarchies of authority and
competence and they're like they're
oriented towards getting a certain task
done and they actually do get the task
done so but we're dubious about our own
ethical what would you say integrity and
I guess that's also why it's a
particular importance for people to try
to act honestly because if you know what
act honestly and then you start to doubt
your own take
and then when people come after you
you're going to be weekd and that's a
really bad idea so